[Musik]
robert habeck und annalena baerbock sind
nach neusten umfragen die beliebtesten
minister lufthansa und ihre tochter
eurowings haben allein im juli 1000
flüge gecancelt grund sind große
personalprobleme und die wut der
deutschen die wird immer größer auch
wegen der nicht aufgearbeiteten corona
politik und damit ja viel gesprächsstoff
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren so für den nach acht schön dass
sie eingeschaltet haben und ich möchte
ihnen jetzt direkt meine gäste
präsentiert josef kraus er ist autor ich
zeige auch mal das buch ist wird
bestimmt das muss ich jetzt zu ihnen
zeigen herr kraus der deutsche
untertanen zeigen wie selber und sieht
auch ehemaliger präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbandes und sein thema heute
abend ist wie das buch heißt der deutsch
untertan wir sind gespannt bild
politikchef und für den r8 stammen
bastian schäfer blickt kritisch auf das
land nichts funktioniert mehr sind wie
eine mangelwirtschaft unser zweiter
stammgast heute abend also für die
stammzuschauer gibt es heute viel zu
sehen ist béla anda ehemaliger
regierungssprecher für sie halb schröder
und deutschlands kommunikationsberater
nummer eins seit überraschen der gedanke
habeck verspricht nur und muss jetzt
endlich auch mal liefert ich bin
gespannt unseren letzten gast den werden
sie kennen ist schon eingeblendet
schauspielerin und spiegel besser
autorin vivien wulf zuletzt hat sie im
traumschiff brilliert aber auch im
kinofilm ist aber heute spricht sie
nicht über die schauspielerei sondern
sorgt sich um unsere kinder denn die
sind so traurig wie noch nie warum das
wird sie uns heute abend erklären aber
erst mal mache ich jetzt mein aufreger
und sprechen über eine andere junge
damen und die heißt emilia fester sie
ist bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen und
hat auf in zügen bürger eingeladen jetzt
werden sie denken das ist doch nett was
soll daran schlimm sein eigentlich ist
es auch eine wirklich schöne idee wenn
frau fester nicht bürger aus grenzen
würde sie schreibt auf instagram ihr
habt vielleicht schon in meinem posting
gesehen von gestern ich würde euch gerne
mit zu einer berlinfahrt nehmen wenn ihr
eine junge frau oder inter trans nicht
binäre person aus hamburg seit lade ich
euch herzlich ein hier sieht man es
eingeblendet alle jungen find hast die
nicht in hamburg wohnen können auch
kommen müssten aber reisen und sich der
gruppe anschließen
falls sie jetzt nicht wissen was hinter
bedeutet dass es kein problem ich muss
es auch denn kinder sind frauen sowie
intern nicht binäre und trans personen
sowie menschen die sich ohne
geschlechtsidentität erleben man stelle
sich jetzt einmal vor ein mann ein
bundestagsabgeordneter würde zu einer
reise nur für männer und alte frauen
ausrufen also ehrlich gesagt das wäre zu
recht ein riesen desaster und ich finde
ausgrenzung sollte keine einbahnstraße
sein was fällt frau fest da eigentlich
ein nur menschen einzuladen die keine
männer und keine älteren frauen sind die
viren wäre es dir auch einen gefallen
das zu tun du bist ja auch eine junge
frau findest du auch männer sollte man
nicht einladen die herr schäfer zu der
reise also ich kann dir sagen ich muss
darüber eigentlich nur schmunzeln weil
wir reden über gender pay gap über über
gleichberechtigung und handeln dann
eigentlich genau im gegenteil genau so
wie bei den ganzen female am powerman
events wo männer ganz klar ausgegrenzt
werden das ist totaler schwachsinn aus
meiner sicht deswegen kann ich das
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen ich bin
ja mal gespannt wie die abstimmung nicht
darum geht die frage auf ist ja und die
diskriminierungs beauftragt ihn zu
wählen müsste sie ja eigentlich dagegen
steigen da kann man schon mal jetzt sehr
gespannt sein dürfen finden sie denn
sonst so frau fest also wenn sie das so
lesen eine reise die wird ja dann auch
vom steuerzahler gezahlt also es wird ja
eingeladen es wird auch darüber gebucht
das macht frau fest da jetzt nicht
privat sie werden auf jeden fall raus
kann ich ihnen aber
bestimmt auch alten sicherheitsmänner
sexuelle identität eine der richtungen
der 60 da hätten sie vielleicht eine
chance also ich weiß zu wenig von ihr
die auszüge die ich auf youtube gesehen
habe ihr die bundestagsrede muss ich
sagen also das ist eines hohen hauses
nicht würdig diese art von intel
infantilisierung diese inszeniert wenn
ich das einmal sagen darf die bernina
ich schätze dichte das was mich wundert
ehrlich gesagt dass du dich wunders denn
wir haben es ja bei den grünen
eigentlich mit einer partei zu tun die
permanent ausgrenzt eine partei die
eigentlich dadurch dass sie wie eine
monstranz vor sich her trägt führt das
gute zu kämpfen immer die ausgrenzt
beispielsweise die zu viel fleisch essen
oder die zu viel rauch und die zu
schnell auto fahren suv und die auf
liegen und wenn wir uns überlegen
während die partei und die fraktion die
ich glaube es war 2 18 21 19 im
bundestag am meisten geflogen ist dann
waren das pro kopf die abgeordneten der
grünen ausgerechnet der grünen von daher
für das toll das thema hassen habe mich
wunder dass das du dich wurden das war
das eigentlich ganz normal die grünen
grenzen gerne aus
ich sehe das etwas lockerer nicht weil
diese muss sondern weil ich mein gott
der mann fest er ist glaube ich ist die
jüngste abgeordnete im deutschen
bundestag
23 jahre als ich schon seit langem
politisch aktiv kommt aus einer
künstlerfamilie sagt ihre eltern haben
sie politisiert oder ist er politisiert
worden im haushalt und reitet natürlich
was wenn man das so locker sagen kann
auf diesem ticket ist wahrscheinlich
auch ihre überzeugung der frau der
frauenpolitik und der jugend
entsprechend und immer mehr junge
politiker die gerade in den bundestag
kommen wer frauen schlägt ist nicht
leisten sich noch gesang ältere frauen
auch nicht also nur junge frauen möchte
ja an ihrer in ihrer in ihrer post sie
in ihrem ihr in ihrem umkreis in ihrem
umfeld und es gibt in amerika sein
wirkliches vorbild auch für sie
heißt sie alexander otte scott es die
ist die ist natürlich so ein vorbild für
viele kämpferische frauen gerade von der
linken und ich denke mal dass sie sich
das auch zum vorbild nimmt hier so zu
agieren also neben ihrer überzeugung
überbesetzt sie da eine politische lücke
um sich zu profilieren und
hat die aufmerksamkeit die sich hier
wünscht ja grundsätzlich finde ich das
ja gut junge frauen zu stärken und ich
glaube das ist auch super wichtig aber
warum nicht auch junge männer warum
müssen die dann ausgeschlossen werden
das verstehe ich nicht warum müssen die
eigentlich jung und alt geben also ich
glaube das ist ja glaube ich der punkt
wahrscheinlich wollten sie das gar nicht
so sagen aber am ende soll doch jeder
die möglichkeit haben ich finde ist auch
in ordnung wenn man sagt ich gehe auf
reisen und suche mir die person aus als
freiheitsliebender mensch würdig sein
das muss jedem erlaubt sein zu sagen ich
nehme nur ich gehe auf reise und ihn nur
diese runde mit und niemand anderem dann
ist das doch in ordnung aber sie machte
wenn man gewahrt gleichzeitig auch im
bundestag auftritt und für oder gegen
diskriminierung das große wort führt und
das harte schwert dann in der tat ist es
ein bisschen also ich muss schon mehr
die würde des hohen hauses zurückkommen
und das passt einfach nicht dazu das ist
ein auftreten was sie bei einer
kindergarten erzieherinnen oder das ist
ja auftreten dass sie bei einer lehrerin
oder gar einer schule darin was sie
nicht werden könnte mit diesem
hintergrund an diesem alter überhaupt
nicht akzeptieren würden ja ich erwarte
mir egal in welcher fraktion dass
volksvertreter ihnen
stehen ich hab schon gelernt sie können
ihre ganzen
ja gut da komme ich gerne noch mehr
rausholen kommen wir einmal zudem sehr
spannenden gedanken von miranda der
gesagt hat dass sie jetzt auch politisch
ein ticket besetzt was die
aufmerksamkeit beschert am anfang muss
man ja auch auffallen und wenn er
politik dann später karriere machen
finden sie denn nicht dass es dort ein
ticket gibt veranda angesprochen hat was
braucht er jetzt gerade vielleicht gut
besetzt also
es gibt so viele möglichkeiten mit
verlaub das erinnert mich etwas ganz
anderes ach ja und das ist jetzt gut
verlaufen es gibt so viele möglichkeiten
in deutschland im vorpolitischen raum
und den politischen raum aktiv zu werden
da muss es nicht gleich an der spitze
ein ndb mandat seien ja dann soll sie
sich was weiß ich wo sie bestimmte
reinpassen würde in der böll stiftung
engagieren oder in der antonio amodeo
oder amadeu antonio stiftung engagieren
oder bei den jungen grünen engagieren
also da bin ich fast für was mir ja auch
bei kanzler haben und natürlich ideen
haben da bin ich fast nicht unbedingt
hören mindestalter von 40 aber
vielleicht wenigstens stück reife daher
bei den jungen grünen warum heißt es
nicht grün innen bei den jungen grünen
phase jahr tatsächlich auch lange zeit
und hat da so ihre politischen
foundation ihren ihrer ihre basis gelegt
und ist dann durch ein mann als mentee
tatsächlich auch dann weiter gekommen
ich finde aber diese gesamte gesagt
ganze debatte die wir auch für ihn auch
ein bisschen verrückt weil man merkt
dass ja wie unsicher viele menschen sind
schon wenn sie dieses thema besetze
nicht verletzungspausen veranstaltung
der kriegten die frau in einem
blumenstrauß und die männern buch und da
habe ich gesagt das ist aber auch ein
zeichen von diskriminierung stille im
saal weil keiner wusste wie er damit
umgehen sollte nicht nur nicht das ist
natürlich dass ich gebe dem buch ich
krieg nicht verstehen warum nur oder und
das jeweilige buch was vielleicht
die mit dem buch weil ich finde männer
brauchen blumensträuße die warum nicht
aber das buch nicht alle bekommen
deshalb nur die männer in das schulhaus
gottschalk auch so am ende von wetten
dass gab es immer für dich mal frauen
sind wir richtig heikel wurstelt bittet
wenn es das buch wäre hätte ich ja nix
war ein sportwagen buch insofern war es
denn sicher ob es gibt
aber jetzt kommen wir mal von den luxus
problem die natürlich auch mein aufreger
des tages sind wenn man darauf blickt
wie deutschland gerade da steht zu den
wirklichen problemen die wir haben dass
es nicht im milieu fester sondern die
these die jan schäfer sollte mitgebracht
hat ja es regt mich eigentlich gar nicht
so stark auf es besorgt mich eigentlich
mehr dass wir in einem land leben in dem
der mangel mehr oder weniger zum alltag
geworden bis zum einen was das thema
straßenbrücken angeht der
verkehrsminister hat angekündigt dass er
bis zu 400 brücken pro jahr jetzt
sanieren möchte einfach weil sie so
marode sind wir sehen also zum einen es
gibt mangel in den schulen auf den
straßen bei den brücken aber es gibt
auch mangel beim personal und das
erkennen wir in diesen tagen immer
deutlich haben vor allem mit blick auf
den sommerurlaub in nordrhein westfalen
stehen die großen sommerferien an es
droht ein riesiges flugchaos am
kommenden wochenende am flughafen an den
flughäfen in nordrhein-westfalen warum
weil das bodenpersonal fehl weil es
nicht genug ab fertiger in den flughäfen
gibt tausende flüge sind abgesagt worden
für diesen sommer warum weil es nicht
genug bord mitarbeiter gibt piloten
flugbegleiter die fehlen
schwimmbäder und frei wieder machen
früher zu und sperren morgens später auf
warum war es nicht mehr genug
bademeister und personal gibt wir sehen
das auch in restaurants und kneipen ganz
häufig heißt es um 21 oder um 22 uhr wir
machen dicht und wir sind noch gar nicht
am ende dieser entwicklung sind am
anfang zur zeit gibt es rund 1,7
millionen offene stellen in deutschland
1,7 millionen aber es gibt bereits
untersuchungen die sagen bis 2030 20 ich
gibt es fünf millionen beschäftigte zu
wenig bei uns das heißt das was wir
jetzt erleben den mangel der sich so
langsam in dieses land rein frisst der
wird noch viel viel größer viel viel
stärker dass das was mich besorgte das
heißt auch die politik muss umdenken sie
muss um steuern sie muss alles dafür tun
nicht nur dass menschen in beschäftigung
kommen aber auch dass menschen nicht
jobs machen die sinnlos sind weil sie
sich um bürokratie kümmern weil sie hier
irgendwelche akten lesen müssen die
eigentlich unnötig sind die also
arbeitskraft binden die woanders viel
viel produktiver eingesetzt werden würde
also deutschland darf nicht zu einem
land werden wo es heißt geht nicht
gibt's doch sondern es muss weiter
gelten geht nicht das gibt es auch nicht
jan in deiner position als politikchef
welches zeugnis für das tue denn gerade
der politik dafür verleihen wie sie in
der mangelwirtschaft umgeht wie aktiv
dagegen man muss natürlich jetzt sehen
die ampel regierung die bundesregierung
ist erst seit einem halben jahr im amt
und ist da sozusagen rhein geworfen
worden aber wir haben eine
bundesregierung davor eine große
koalition die am stück acht jahre
regiert hat und dir das thema natürlich
verschlafen insgesamt stellen wir auch
fest wir haben es irgendwie alle auch
über letzten zwei jahre gar nicht so
mitbekommen weil wir natürlich die lok
downs hatten die korona zeit zwei sommer
lang in denen auch viele hotels gar
nicht richtig geöffnet hatten in dem
viele leute oder in den sommern in denen
viele leute zu hause geblieben sind weil
sie gesagt haben ich bleib mal lieber
hier wer weiß ob ich überhaupt nach
österreich und nach spanien komme da ist
das ganze nicht so aufgefallen aber
jetzt ist das wie bei einer
ketchupflasche am anfang tröpfelt nur
und diese noch mal merken wir es kommt
richtig einen flaschen raus auf den
teller und wir stellen fest die
mangelwirtschaft die erfasst uns wie
gesagt nicht nur beim thema
infrastruktur sondern jetzt auch beim
thema beim thema personal das bricht an
allen ecken und enden raus und es ist ja
nicht nur die sozusagen die sommer
wirtschaft es ist der paketfahrer der
vedes ist das pflegepersonal das fehlt
obwohl wir immer mehr pfleger haben wir
haben nicht weniger aber immer mehr gibt
es auch da immer noch zu wenig wir sehen
es bei fachkräften langes thema also
eigentlich die gesamte bandbreite an
jobs in deutschland
ist betroffen es gibt viel mehr
nachfrage extrem viel nachfrage aber zu
wenig arbeitskräfte angebot nun ist ja
ein schäfer ja eigentlich ein großer
verfechter des markt nicht also mag muss
es regeln mag soll das regeln politik
soll die nicht rein politik gespannt was
hier kommt es war ich mich wie wie
erklärst du dir denn jetzt und uns da
hin weil das die politik jetzt unbedingt
handeln muss was der markt normalerweise
regelt aber vielleicht noch dazu ja wir
haben und da stimme ich dir völlig zu
das gefühl dass nichts mehr funktioniert
in deutschland egal ob du mit der bahn
fährt oder ob du mit dem auto fährst
oder mit dem flugzeug fährst und die
frage ist halt insofern bin ich auch ein
bisschen beide in diesem punkt wer
regelt das eigentlich und das gefühl ist
da es ist keiner da das regelt weil es
allen egal im endeffekt und das darf
natürlich nicht sein aber nochmal zurück
der macht auf die normale worte
aufrichtig auch sofort ein recht wenn
der markt es regeln sollte beim thema
rente beispielsweise und klassischer
fall bei dem versucht wird der markt bei
der rente regel sowieso nicht viel aber
wo man sagen könnte wenn die menschen
immer älter werden dann müssten sie
eigentlich auch später in die rente
genau das zum beispiel verhindern die
sozialdemokraten vehement die cdu hat
mit verhindert die ampel fährt auch und
die rente jetzt mit den flugzeugen und
mit den bahnen zog die hat mit dem
personalmangel extrem viel zu tun denn
wir kommen in eine phase in der
stichwort baby boomer immer mehr
menschen in rente gehen aber immer
weniger junge leute in den arbeitsmarkt
hineinwachsen deswegen kommen wir zu
einer lücke die zur zeit bei rund
450.000 licht zu einer lücke von
ungefähr fünf millionen im jahr 20 31 es
regelt es denn der markt und natürlich
der planwirtschaft sei alles andere aus
dem planwirtschaftlich also auch für den
markt ja natürlich bin ich für den markt
aber der markt muss auch die richtigen
impulse setzen ich fühle mich da jetzt
ein bisschen gekitzelt was sie sagen als
als außerparlamentarische
bildungspolitiker ja wir haben die
situation in den letzten 15 jahren dass
wir mehr studenten studieren da muss man
heute sagen mehr studenten haben
studienanfänger als leute die eine
berufliche bildung anfangen und da haben
wir ja auch den mangel ja wir haben das
muss ich jetzt mit einer gewissen
provokanten absicht sagen wir haben zu
viele junge leute die relativ
überflüssige fächer studieren
irgendwas mit medien und die sollten
jetzt lieber kenner werden in
gaststätten arbeiten
zumal es ist vor 20 30 jahren den jungen
leuten reich gemacht worden der mensch
beginnt beim abitur vor ein paar jahren
hilfe stand der mensch beginnt mit
hochschulabschluss wie bachelor in den
beruf der schauspielerin herr kraus wenn
wir immer berufen ist sehr wichtig genug
der frau wulff den weiter ausüben oder
sollte sie jetzt auch lieber schnell den
personalmangel bei den deckel drauf
setzt auch mithelfen ich will sich ja
nicht um schwul ist eine ernst gemeinte
frage um zu verstehen was sie meinen mit
berufen die nicht wichtig sind oder
nicht man sie nicht braucht das
sind ausgedünnten und wir kriegen die
auch nicht bis jetzt diesen positionen
durch zuwanderung das gilt ja immer als
es das große patent rezept
könnte man vielleicht jetzt
über den vorschlag der nicht erst von
steinmeier kam nachdenken
pflichtdienst jahres was das problem ein
bisschen größer ist schon wieder
gestorben was ist also das problem lösen
also dass der klempner jetzt ist mache
ich einen pflicht gleich ein halbes jahr
in einem auto zu bleiben habe aber zum
altwerk ja du bist ja auch selber das
aber dem aussetzen der wehrpflicht ja
dann ein riesen loch entstanden ist in
den grad der pflegenotstand kommt aber
nicht durch die aussetzung der
wehrpflicht der sehr freuen aber ich
hätte dann halt unter denen die nicht
zur bundeswehr gehen wollen und die also
den ersatzdienst machen hätte ich ein
jahr lang leute die da zumindest
hilfsdienst jährlichen unmotivierte
menschen sollen sich um
den schwiegervater die mutter kümmern
das möchte ich ehrlich wie möglich trägt
keine andere lösung klar ich denke dass
pädagogisch ich denke dafür bogisch es
kann doch von einem jungen menschen der
eine lebensphase lang
79 jahre bei männlichen neugeborenen
liebliche erwartung 84 bei weiblichen
neugeborenen wird wahrscheinlich sich
noch steigern der sein leben lang von
der infrastruktur des landes
sie hatten zwei jahre gelitten hat
während der krone abwehr nicht seine
träume leben konnte ja
verlangen dass der ein ja dieses immer
längeren lebens in das gemeinwesen das
im schuppen bietet investiert ohne jetzt
darüber zu debattieren ob es das also ob
es jetzt richtig ist oder nicht ich bin
dagegen aber er würde es das denn lösen
also glauben sie wenn wir jetzt
ja dann sind wir durch plötzlich
reiniger seine maßnahme ja und dann bin
ich schon auch marktwirtschaftler dann
muss halt der markt ist es der klempner
ist oder irgendein anderer dienstleister
ist muss halt so attraktive angebote
haben dass der sagt okay da
krieg ich das gleiche wie wenn ich was
man sich irgendwann medien müssen
wissenschaftler machen und was brauchen
wir um die medien wir sind wir merken
wir brauchen noch auch eine kultur der
verantwortlichkeit wenn ich jeden tag
lese dass in den flughäfen aus in
münchen witzigerweise in deutschland das
personal fehlt wohin sich koffer türmen
in den abflug zahlen die nirgendwohin
mehr zugestellt werden da muss doch
irgendjemand sagen der verantwortlich
ist okay das ist unser flughafen das ist
der flughafen der landesregierung wo die
das land vielleicht beteiligt ist das
ist wohl dieses landesregierung sitzt
wir fühlen uns dafür zuständig wenn eine
baustelle fünf jahre lang eine baustelle
es muss doch jemand sagen der zuständige
bauminister freunde geht das nicht
schneller wenn ähnliche beispiele da
sind die sogenannten zügen war ich bis
heute habe ich einen reklame gesehen für
den sport bistro da kann ich wirklich
nur lachen bei jedem bordbistro ich
verfilzung dass ich da hinter vielen
entwickeln speisen fehlt das personal
oder die klimatisierung ist ausgefallen
sind dass das ding sowieso geschlossen
ist also es muss doch jemand
verantwortung übernehmen für diese
missstände und sagen wir wollen das
ändern und das vermisse ich und das muss
sein weil es hat sich auch seine
attitüde eingependelt das werk ich sehe
ich auf der bahn auch zog ist verspätet
gucke ich halt noch ein bisschen netflix
auch egal das darf ja auch nicht sein
und niemand regt sich mehr auf aus der
alte weiße männer vielleicht
über diese missstände und das ist etwas
was die die kultur uns wäre ja nie
sierung des herrn das ja eigentlich mal
aber die zerbröselt dadurch die kultur
des landes und alles was damit zu tun
hat beide politiker auch immer nur fünf
jahre voraus ich glaube der punkt aber
die neuen macht hat er ist ein ganz
wichtiger dass sie gesagt haben das ist
eine zeitlang ja in der politik
eigentlich üblich war zu sagen wenn du
nicht abitur gemacht hast bist du
eigentlich kein wertvoller oder
gleichwertiger mensch und das ist das
was das handwerk beispielsweise auch
beklagt und wenn man sich überlegt dass
man heutzutage im durchschnitt auf einen
handwerker egal welche dienstleistung im
durchschnitt neun wochen warten muss
wenn man einen elektriker braucht wir
haben die erfahrung gesetzt in berlin
gemacht zum teil drei monate warten muss
weil die bücher einfach sofort und dass
er sagt ja in drei monaten können wieder
anrufen vielleicht haben sie glück
vielleicht auch pech dabei ist das dann
schreit das ja geradezu danach zu sagen
leute geht ins handwerk macht etwas und
werdet richtig richtig reich mit ganz
toller ehrlicher arbeit und jan warum
das vielleicht nicht klappt dann haben
wir auch ihre these
zu bekommen
da hat auch aber die wirtschaft versorgt
weil auch die wirtschaft jahrelang den
abiturienten dem realschüler vorgezogen
hat und die schüler den hauptschüler
vorgezogen hat und da hat sich in den
köpfen der eltern natürlich fest
geschützt aber okay fließender übergang
sie sind daran dass mit ihrer these die
sie heute abend präsentieren möchten
einladung zur diskussion am tisch von
ihnen heinrich heine hat vor fast 200
jahren gesagt untertanen treue ist so
ein schönes gefühl es ist so ein
wahrhaft großes gefühl
und ich habe mir die mühe gemacht mal
ein bisschen historische aufzulisten
warum der deutsche sich seit 500 jahren
so ziemlich alles gefallen lässt
und wenn er sich mal etwas nicht
gefallen lässt dann nach oben durch
notiert mit hurra 1914 mit uran 233 und
31 aber ich glaube es gibt kaum ein land
die nation darf man fast denken wir
sagen dass sich so viel gefallen lässt
bis zum heutigen tag ja schauen sich die
bevölkerung an
scharf geduldig erträgt sie die
steigerung der energiepreise schaafs
geduldig erträgt sie die 7,9 prozent
wahrscheinlich sind die schon schön
gerechnet inflationsrate schaafs
geduldig erträgt der deutsche michel wie
er
meine tägliche
gehirnwäsche gib mir heute bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen ich glaube das
darf man die runde ja sagen gibt da
keinen gibt da keine tatort der nicht
politisch korrekt durchgestylt ist und
so weiter und so weiter mehr er lässt
sich sagen du hast antifaschistisch zu
sein du hast anti kolonialistisch zu
sein du hast antirassistisch zu sein und
so weiter und so weiter mehr und der
deutsche er trägt ist duldete sie
wollten auch wirklich gehirnwäsche sagen
oder nicht dass sie jetzt im eifer des
gefechts also gehirnwäsche sehen sie
wirklich unter dem see gelegt hier hab
ich gesagt haben wir versprochen und
seine technik werde
wir haben ein bisschen zu diesem unfug
der gender sprache wenig zdf anschauen
will ich überhaupt noch zdf ist ja da
noch viel schöner als die ja das war der
kleber der hat angefangen damals die
petra gerster mit diesem glockenschlag
wo ich mir gedacht habe ich glaube die
nachrichtensprecher neuerdings zdf zu
sehen jetzt
logopädie bedürftige somit schmolz auf
deutsch gesagt es ist einfach holz und
der deutschen sprache und 80 prozent ist
deutschen mittel wollen es eigentlich
nicht die ich kenne die umfragen gibt es
mehrere aber der deutsche mittel steht
nicht dagegen auf ist so brav seine acht
milliarden gebühren er kauft weiterhin
den audi obwohl die jetzt mit audianer
rinnen angesprochen werden haben jetzt
im moment den prozess den entsprechenden
prozess beim landgericht ingolstadt die
kirchen machen es mit das bistum
katholische bistum hildesheim gibt eine
gender fieber aus für kinder sprache usw
und der deutsche mitteln
ehemals vertreter
des volks der dichter und denker lässt
somit seiner sprache umgeht aber gut da
könnte ich ihnen jetzt zig beispiele
nennen ich lasse ich jetzt mal so bei
diesem ersten kleinen rundumschlag also
die zusammenfassung ist bürger wehrt
euch da fragen wir doch direkt mal béla
anda ob er noch ein audi kaufen würde ob
man da jetzt schon wer gehen muss gegen
dafür keine schleichwerbung machen aber
ich fahre da hat sich ein audi
ich finde das sogar gut das war ja nicht
freiwillig bei audi sondern das war
erzwungen glaube ich durchs gericht
nicht dass diese sprach erweiterung dazu
kommt ich bin ja habe ich ja schon
mehrfach ihr geortet als jemand der
gendern gar nicht schlecht findet weil
der deutsche michel ja wo ist die
michelin bei ihnen auf dem cover wenn
ich mir da drauf gucke also insofern
warum sollten wir nur der pilot sein und
nicht die piloten einig die reifen ich
finde die ist die einschränkung ist
tatsächlich keine die die gut ist im
endeffekt und deswegen bin ich auch
dagegen aber bei ihnen ist das ja
interessant im grunde weise sie sind ja
nicht nur autor sondern sie sind ja auch
im grunde chef pädagoge und treten ja
auch als der auf und sieht lange als
eine solche aufgetreten wir zahlen ja
glaub es 20 jahre das heft ist 30 jahre
chef des lehrerverbandes und ich mir
angucke was alles in unseren schulen
schiefläuft und schief gelaufen ist dann
frage ich mich wo waren sie als es darum
ging wer tatsächlich gerechtigkeit in
schulen einzuführen wo waren sie als es
darum ging mehr ganztagsschulen
einzuführen wo waren sie als es darum
gegen mehr betreuung an den schulen
einzuführen also 30 jahre offenbar nicht
so viel gemacht und jetzt kluge worte
machen da frage ich mich was ist denn da
schiefgelaufen das könnte auch fragen
was ist in der regierung
aber jetzt jetzt lassen wir mal dass ich
war 20 jahre lang haben sich moment
moment ich war 20 jahre lang chef eines
gymnasiums und das ist eines eine schule
von 42.000 in deutschland also was da
für sie auch noch tief sie waren
präsident des deutschen lebertag
1987 bis zweijähriges aber die
bildungspolitik machen ja immer noch die
länder und nicht irgendein verband die
talkshows klang als er beim anders
ja wir waren ja noch nie
geschadet habe die politik beraten und
ich habe gesagt dass aus dem
parlamentarischer berater und ich war
immer dafür dass wir ein
leistungsorientiertes schulsystem haben
keines dass eine inflation an
abiturzeugnissen usw betreibt ich habe
ein anderes verständnis von
gerechtigkeit
ich setze gerechtigkeit nicht wie sie
mit mit der gleichheit gleich ich glaube
damals unterschiedliche verständnis
etwas gleichheit und gerechtigkeit
ich habe hochachtung immer gehabt vor
dem hauptschul absolventen verdienen der
eine berufliche bildung gemacht der
mensch beginnt nicht beim abitur ich
habe gewarnt vor knapp drei jahren
natürlich corona hat da jetzt mache ich
natürlich wieder
an pädagogische güte hochgejubelt aber
wenn ich jetzt in der zeit der abitur
der der verleihung der abiturzeugnisse
see ist es gibt ja kaum ein gymnasium
noch wo nicht mindestens 50 prozent der
1,4 dem komma haben also dass das ist
der ungedeckten scheck aus was sie hier
machen ist oder ihrem plädoyer war ja
ein sehr vielschichtiges also einmal
ging es um die frage lässt sich und bill
hat das ja auch noch mal wiederholt oder
auch aufgebraucht ist schön dass ich mit
dem rollstuhl durch und stehen wir heute
alles bieten das ist vollkommen richtig
sie sind hierbei bild eine etwas
zugespitzte formulierung beispielsweise
hierbei bild gar nicht mit dem gender
stern schreiben das machen viele andere
so die sagen dann auch eine kurze pause
eine kunstpause und sprechen dann weiter
das tun wir alles nicht und ich glaube
das ist auch gut so dass wir das nicht
und weil einfach auch sprach er nicht
operiert werden darf schlimm reingehört
der weise und nichtleben der serie law
weise wenn an schulen so geschrieben
wird in offiziellen briefen
beispielsweise an die eltern die
eigentlich mit der offiziellen
schreibweise die die kinder lernen im
unterricht überhaupt nichts zu tun hat
bestes beispiel die einladung zum ersten
elternabend für erstklässler sternchen
innen die zufällig vor ein paar wochen
bei uns ins haus schwebte da fällt mir
nicht mehr viel zu eigentlich glaube
dass erstklässler sternchen innen
so was von absolut
report ist es absolut daneben ist die
erstklässler wissen meistens gerade ob
sie mit ihrer junge sind was das
sternchen da soll ist mir völlig hat es
bei mir ihr leben völlig frage und da
glaube ich ist ein wichtiger punkt den
sie machen
wir schreiben aus ideologie oder an
schulen wird aus ideologischen gründen
vom lehrpersonal auch von der
schulleiterin und dem schulleiter anders
geschrieben als es offiziell gelehrt
wird und das ist da glaube ich zeigt
sich der ganze irrsinn und die ganzen
polizeiwägen global friedlich dieser
sprache die schienen gelegt jan war ich
glaube herr kraus sie haben ja auch
gemeinden nicht nur was das schulsystem
betrifft generell der deutschunterricht
würde gerne einmalige zeigen ist es sehr
tagesaktuell das will ich auch ihnen
nicht vorenthalten je mehr zuschauer und
zwar karl lauterbach was ihm gerade soja
beschäftigt
diejenigen die hier leben und runde
stehen und haben dazu
[Applaus]
seine
stimme ist sein dass sie noch stellen
haben wir richtig
liegen gearbeitet haben dieses wissen
sehr gut wie möglich belastet sind
ja wenn man das hier gesehen hat dann
merkt man ja ganz klar herr lauterbach
unser gesundheitsminister also ein
bundesminister spricht eigentlich den
menschen das recht ab zur demonstration
gegen die impfung und da würde ich gerne
einmal natürlich schon viele andere
fragen nicht nur bei dem auftritt habe
ich mich gewundert in der vergangenheit
aber wie viel muss denn eigentlich
passiere das muss jetzt gar nicht
auffällt aber bezogen sein bis ein
minister zurücktreten muss gibt es
eigentlich irgendwie bedient auch die
bevölkerung hat wenn wir zum beispiel
keine untertanen mehr sein wollen und
sagen jetzt reicht so lauterbach ja wenn
der widerstand so groß ist dass ein
bundeskanzler oder bundeskanzlerin fühlt
das ist eine wahnsinnige belastung und
das wird sich auch nicht ändern dann
wird es immer den hinweis geben jetzt
ist zeit oder den befehl oder wenn der
mann oder die frau tatsächlich zu
bedrohungen für die regierung wird dann
dann führt man ein solches gespräch in
diesem konkreten fall sein wird ich
glaube zwei sachen einmal ein
rhetorischer trick von karl lauterbach
er steht da auf einer bühne wird
ausgepfiffen versucht diejenigen die ihn
auspfeifen
verteilen diejenigen die ein
berechtigtes interesse haben sagt er und
diejenigen die ein berechtigtes
interesse haben ich finde dass fast in
form tatsächlich was er gemacht mit
denjenigen die die meinung vertreten
dass
impfen nebenwirkungen haben kann sagt
ihr habt gar nichts dazu beigetragen die
situation zu verbessern wenn ich das
jetzt gerade so richtig mitgenommen habe
aus dem kurzen clip und das ist
natürlich so jeder kennt natürlich
beispiele wo impfungen nebenwirkungen
gehabt haben ich kenne solche fälle ich
denke jeder von uns kennt sie zum
zweiten gibt es unglaublich viele
menschen die ein berechtigte sorge
hatten dass ihre kinder geimpft werden
ich bin selber solche fälle das sind
kein geschlecht menschen die haben es
auch nicht verdient von karl lauterbach
hier beschimpft zu werden sondern wir
haben das in der inneren überzeugung
gemacht dagegen kann man sein aber man
darf die leute und diese meinung
ich habe da auch dazugelernt aber nicht
nicht so in den senkel stellen wie er es
gemacht hat zumal nicht als
gesundheitsminister da gilt halt auch
die freiheit der anderen und das geht
überhaupt nicht
die müssen nicht viel hinzuzufügen würde
ich sagen das ist absolut richtig aber
das ist glaube ich etwas was wir bei
karl lauterbach ja eigentlich schon über
monate wenn ich vielleicht sogar über
jahre beobachten können und karl
lauterbach hat eigentlich das große
megathema corona r kämpft derzeit um
anerkennung und versucht dieses thema
corona durch einen sommer zu ziehen
indem überhaupt keine lust auf corona
hat in dem es auch übrigens in seinem
ressort ganz ganz viele andere probleme
gibt die zu regeln sind beispielsweise
das thema krankenkassenfinanzen also der
gesundheitsminister das hat man ja bei
jens spahn auch schon gesehen der hat ja
nicht nur eigentlich mit corona zu tun
der hat so viel anderes zu tun da geht
es um krankenhausfinanzierung da geht es
um die kassen finanzierung es gibt die
pharma branche es gibt auch die privaten
krankenversicherung beispielsweise es
gibt die ärzte die zahl jetzt also ist
ein so vielschichtiges feld und karl
lauterbach das ehrt ihn liest ganz ganz
viele studien nachts was nicht so gut
ist erreicht habe hätten und ach so über
kümmert er sich um krone aber das andere
liegt brach und da wächst auch selbst in
der eigenen fraktion sogar in der
eigenen spd fraktion der unmut über karl
lauterbach weil er einfach nur ja was
ist ja mister corona ist aber nicht der
gesundheitsminister den dieses land
eigentlich bräuchte aber wie wenn du
dass gerade sie ist die demonstration
jesaja die these der deutsch untertan
ist weil sich nur auf die korona
abhängigen bezogen aber sind denn
eigentlich die deutschen dann überhaupt
so untertänig wie hast du das denn in
der korona pandemie wahrgenommen auch
mit blick auf die künstler für
schauspieler auch viel weggefallen ich
glaube einfach dass erst mal viele
unsicher waren keiner wusste auch
wirklich wie er damit umgehen soll und
ich finde also das was herr lauterbach
da von sich gegeben hat funktioniert so
einfach nicht also gerade als politiker
für mich hast du ganz kleine
vorbildfunktion auch und leute da so
immens auszugrenzen wo ja immer noch
viele unsicherheiten haben das
funktioniert hättest du dich als
schauspielerin getraut demonstrieren zu
gehen als person des öffentlichen lebens
in der zeit des winters und wo es so
stark sie zugespitzt hat in deutschland
du meinst wenn ich mich nicht hätte
impfen lassen wollen ja auf jeden fall
warum dann nicht wenn ich dagegen bin
und wirklich auch angst davor habe auf
fal es ist wichtig da seine stimme weißt
du was ich alles und einig ist es ihr
gar nicht frau wolff die schauspieler
werde demonstrieren gegangen weil sie
gegen die impfung gewesen wäre die
menschen demonstrieren gegen herr
lauterbach ich glaube ich habe da
selber eine differenzierte meinung
gefunden ich war zweimal geimpft
gehabt mit der heftigen lungenentzündung
und mein jüngster bruder ist klinikchef
und dem 120 leute gestorben also ich
will da schon differenzieren ja was mich
an lauterbach stört ist dass er mit
angst arbeitet das andere meinung nicht
geltenlässt wegwischt da somit angst
arbeitet ich habe in dem buch unter
anderem auch den begriff der fotografie
geprägt wobei und generalisierte angst
und kathi damit damit herrschen damit
erspart damit kann man natürlich den
deutschen mittel ähnlich sich ja mit der
ganzen liga die partie verfolgt ja
wir werden hat er ja auch gesagt war
kürzlich der
meeresspiegel um sieben meter steigen
oder glaube ich letzte woche mehr
losgelassen und er vergisst aber auch
schnell was er bevor das sich über die
talkshows ins ministeramt ihn
eingelagert hat muss man so bös
formulieren ja er vergisst schnell thema
hospitalisierung rate dass er im
aufsichtsrat der rhön kliniken und in
gutachten für die bertelsmann-stiftung
noch bevor er minister wurde gesagt hat
wir können uns wir können als die hälfte
von den 1800 klinik in deutschland
sparen ja wir können sie schließt
sozusagen ja also da da fehlt es an
glaubwürdigkeit ganz zu schweigen davon
er ist ja auch schon aufgetreten mit
studien auf der basis von zwei versucht
versuchen eine prozent ich glaube das
ist ein sehr guter schlusssatz für ihre
these auch wenn ich das jetzt sage als
moderatorin und ich sehe als gast aber
fehlende glaubwürdigkeit das will ja
keiner damit geben wir eine ganz kurze
unterbrechungen sind gleich wieder
zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
sogar meine damen und herren ball in der
85 köpfen sind meinungen jeder von uns
hat ein thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt
freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht red bull new york will wetten
das auge ist aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der darin führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße
umbuchungen die ratten das thema ist
viel zu wichtig um es nur der ard zu
überlassen lasst den leuten soll man den
spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatale ist in der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
sein dass gerade in eine scotty zum
manko vielleicht einmal kurz einsatz
doch das sind übliche anorak träger
ausdruck zu bringen dass brücken und ich
habe meinen beitrag um eine sache immer
bekommt er kümmert sich darum niemand
man muss da ganz klar auch darüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fair für
mich richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück wir wollen keine zeit
verlieren und geben direkt an béla anda
vielen dank robert habeck ist der
beliebteste politiker deutschlands das
belegen neueste umfragen und der grüne
vizekanzler und wirtschaftsminister ist
so etwas wie der kaiser der umfragen
doch dieser kaiser ist bald nackt denn
was kommt denn wirklich bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern an außer
mahnende oder auch mal für verständnis
werben der worte langsam das gefühl dass
wir auf dem weg in die planwirtschaft
und in die steinzeit sind ja klar ist es
schlimm dass russland unsere
energieabhängigkeit ausnutzt und sie als
waffe einsetzt und ja gewiss ist radio
band habe ich nicht dafür verantwortlich
dass unsere gasspeicher nicht nicht voll
sind sondern dass sie leer waren die
frage ist aber doch was tut diese
regierung dagegen um die situation zu
verändern habe ich war in dubai aber in
katar habe ich war auch in abu dhabi und
hat da verhandelt um lng gas also das
komprimierte gas dass sie ankommen soll
ist davon irgendetwas angekommen oder
auf den weg gebracht ich weiß es nicht
denn seitdem seit diesem besuch ruht
still der see und nichts haben wir
gehört seine beamten schreiben gesetz
umgesetzt aber wird dadurch irgendwas
anders statt dessen erklärungen was
alles nicht geht verlängerung der
akw-laufzeiten geht nicht aussetzen des
verbots für verbrenner ab 2035 geht
nicht wer gas umwandelt im strom soll
dafür bei strafen bezahlen ich finde wir
haben ein absolutes sondersituation und
deswegen müssen auch sonder maßnahmen
ergreifen akw laufzeiten verlängern mit
den brennstäben das kann mir keiner
erzählen dass wir die nicht weiter
bekommen das zweite ist eben jede form
von fossilen energien weiter nutzen für
diese übergangszeit steinkohle
braunkohle und vor allen dingen brauchen
wir eine positive vision für die zukunft
und nicht alles wird schlimmer oder
alles wird noch schlimmer als bei corona
sondern wir müssen sagen wie wir es
hinbekommen und uns auf den weg machen
es gemeinsam zu schaffen das wünsche ich
mir von einem vizekanzler der ja bald
auch gerne bundeskanzler werden will wer
mich freut es einerseits mich betrübt
dass mich freut es natürlich dass robert
habeck
wirtschaftsminister wird und du danach
für die verlängerung der
atomlaufzeiten bis um das richtig
erinnere akw ich das richtig sehe ich in
der situation wir vor sechs monaten hier
nämlich noch gesprochen und da war das
anders ja da war ich noch dass ich sagte
du hast doch die atommeiler länger
laufen nein das können gar nicht sein
aber das ist doch gut dass robert habeck
sozusagen alle schafft aber auf den
punkt wenn du gemacht hast er ist
vollkommen richtig robert habeck
versucht die situation auszunutzen und
versucht sich nach der gescheiterten
kanzlerkandidatur von annalena baerbock
als künftiger kanzlerkandidat jetzt
schon in stellung zu bringen hätte auch
das pre bei den grünen das ist ganz klar
hat es mit einer spd zu tun die
erkennbar schwächelt aber die große
gefahr lauert genau in dem was du
geschrieben hast wie schlimm wird der
perfekte sturm den wir jetzt sehen neuer
schock also extrem hohe inflation
lieferketten problematik krieg wenn das
alles zusammenkommt dann sehen wir an
den börsen bereits es geht dramatisch
runter und wir werden einen in eine lage
kommen wenn das thema energie so
dramatisch bleibt wie es ist dass robert
habeck wirklich möglicherweise am ende
der legislaturperiode 20 25 als der
minister da steht der den leuten
verkaufen muss warum sie eigentlich
deutlich an wohlstand verloren haben und
trotzdem glücklich sein soll und wenn
jetzt der economy stupid dann wird
robert habeck ein veritables problem
erkannt das tut er ja schon im voraus in
der versicherungswirtschaft nennt man
das erwarten menschen werden heute weiß
nachdem dort seien richtig absoluten er
tut es ja so ist ja alles wird schlimmer
aber was ich auch erwarte ist wege
aufzuzeigen wie es nicht schlimmer
sondern bessere ein bundeskanzler und
das ist glaube ich dann die kernfrage zu
der es kommen wird da kann man sagen ja
du hast uns ja vorbereitet darauf dass
schlimmer wird aber robert habeck muss
die perspektive aufzeigen und so sind
wir menschen zum glück ja gestrickt dass
wir es eigentlich immer besser haben
wollen nicht nur für uns selbst aber
auch für die kinder und kindeskinder der
muss den weg aufzeigen wie wir
eigentlich zu mehr wohlstand kommen und
das geht nicht immer in dem man den
gürtel enger schnallt sondern man muss
sich vielen anderen gürtel zu legen der
andere hose aber muss irgendwas neu und
anders machen die ich wage mal die
prognose
als psychologe haben sie vergessen
ich bin auch diplomierter psychologe
aber das sage ich normalerweise nicht
dürfen sie auch ja sagen
ich war gespannt jetzt ich habe aber
keinen röntgenblick ja aber nein ich bin
überzeugt vom schloss das hab ich noch
manche wendungen machen wird und er wird
über kurz oder lang bei allen problemen
wie mir brennstäben haben so weiter
abend in ruhiger müsste man jetzt schon
anfangen die brennstäbe etwas zu schonen
im sommer das sie dann in sechs jahren
laufen bis die neuen brennstäbe kommen
und so weiter und so weiter er wird
irgendwann auch mal wieder zu einer
verlängerung der noch drei laufenden
einzig bei mir zu hause ausziehen und
sogar 1
willkommen
in der psychologie nennt man das einen
konvertiten alpha aber jetzt will ich
schon mal gehört konvertiten einfach nur
die grünen man merkt dass die lehrer
waren jetzt gerade hat man das gemerkt
sie möchten was beibringen das ist gut
konvertiten alpha ist einer der war mal
sage ich jetzt mal katholisch und dann
ist der protestantisch geworden und
protestantische sodann 300% ich wollte
mein chefredakteur der welt auf den traf
das gut so da war vorher bei den grünen
dann ja ok ok und die grünen machen
exerzieren diesen konvertiten eifer im
moment was rüstung betrifft
ja sie haben ihren militanten
strammen pazifismus über bord geworfen
und machen wenn ich mir den wert der
hofreiter anschauen machen jetzt stramm
auf falls ja da gibt es einen einen
unterschied die anti atomkraft bewegung
war die keimzelle die dna für die grünen
und robert habeck deswegen ist es sehr
spannend hat schon vor wenigen wochen
einmal ins spiel gebracht die meiler der
akw länger laufen zu lassen da ist
sofort ein sturm der entrüstung aus der
grünen umweltministerium den
umweltministern aus einem grünen ecken
über ihn hereingebrochen oder musste
zurückziehen aber vielleicht ist er da
schon weiter als wir alle denken nur die
grünen machen da nicht mit ich bin im
übrigen nicht für eine grundsätzliche
aufhebung des ausstiegs bei den akw es
aber dafür die jetzt länger laufen zu
lassen um diese unglaubliche situation
der bedrohung zu zu find das
bemerkenswert was da passiert ist was es
gerade schon ein bisschen angesprochen
was zu beginn des krieges in der
bundesregierung passiert ist als robert
habeck ende februar sagte man müsse
jetzt auch als erkennbar war dass beim
thema gas zu problemen kommt dass wir
uns lösen müssen von russischem gas und
öl und gesagt wir müssen das
ergebnisoffen prüfen dann kam ein sturm
der entrüstung und es dauerte gefühlt 48
stunden vielleicht war es auch 72 und
dann stand für die bundesregierung in
form von robert habeck und der
umweltministerin steffi lemke fest dass
es beim thema kernkraft auf keinen fall
aus den verschiedensten gründen zu einer
laufzeitverlängerung kommen kann
interessant ist wenn es um
straßenbau geht wenn irgendwo eine
besondere kröte dann am straßenrand
auftaucht dann werden gutachten über
gutachten angefordert dann wird für ein
halbes jahr nicht gebaut weil es ja
diese eine kröte da am straßenrand gibt
die ganz besonders ist und dass wir
nicht so interessant hier geht es um ein
ganzes land hier geht es um drei mal
geht es um die stromversorgung für am
ende natürlich nicht 80 millionen
deutsche aber ein teil von 80 deutschen
und für die bundesregierung in form von
harnik und frau lemke am ende auch des
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz steht
innerhalb von wenigen tagen fest warum
man einen entscheidenden faktor aus der
stromerzeugung am ende des jahres raus
nimmt das ist einfach nur idealer weg
und hat nichts mit pragmatismus rennen
nicht ich sagen als ich überlege im
moment immer wenn ich sehe habeck
sympathiewerte die umfragen wenn sich
vorstellen würde ein friedrich merz oder
ein mann der union würde das machen mit
qatar dieses video also ich finde vieles
doch auch die person robert habeck sell
frage ist das würde robert habeck machen
wenn friedrich merz das gemacht das war
dann tun oder auch wie würden teile der
presse dann auch friedrich merz losgehen
wir sind will ich mal fragen wie wie in
wohl wie empfindest du das denn ist
robert habeck ein guter typ kannst du
verstehen die sympathiewerte für ihn in
diesem land ja also um nochmal darauf
gegeben was ich halt schwierig findet
das große ganze wird nicht gesehen sehr
an dieser grünen ideologie festgehalten
und das bereitet uns ja gerade eine
schwierige situation
um auf deine frage zurückzukommen robert
habeck privat für mich sowieso schon mal
falsche partei dementsprechend gar keine
option aber ansonsten bisher vor allem
auch bei frauen gut ankommen würde sonst
tatsächlich nicht so nachvollziehen weil
er ist mir also der quatscht halt immer
uns irgendwie nicht so zittern nicht
durch und dementsprechend aber er ist in
portion intellektueller als zu einer
kandidatin die hatte und was mir heute
auch auf einen nenner berbalk
kandidatin wissen sie was ich
bemerkenswert finde weil ich sage immer
mehr zum haben die können sich über
kurze daran gut miteinander entspannt
sich doch jetzt in schleswig holstein an
obwohl ja wie heißt du große günther
auch andere optionen gehabt hätte
und s bahn zügen oder das vor allem im
bevölkerungsreichsten land an die können
miteinander die zukunft heißt schwarz
grün haben sie das habe kanzler kann das
vielleicht sogar grün schwarz möglich
ich kann natürlich kann das besser als
annalena baerbock die antwort auf die
frage
das
wort was glauben sie mir ich meine wenn
ich mir die wenn ich mir die
energiepläne so ehrbar design mögen
anschaue dann höre ich immer nur
von seiten auch der grünen das muss
klappen das muss klappen dass wir 80
prozent unseres stroms stroms 2030 aus
erneuerbaren energien bekommen 80% wir
sind jetzt bei ungefähr etwas über 40
prozent innerhalb von acht jahren
eigentlich müssen wir den anteil
verdoppeln und wenn man fragt wird das
dann klingen wie wie soll das gelingen
dann heißt es aus der ampel koalition
auch von anderen parteimitgliedern das
muss gelingen aber müssen ist das eine
können ist das andere und das ist das
was ich extrem besorgniserregend finde
dass wir dir dass ich den augen habe
hier wird gar nicht mit einem doppelten
boden gespielt sondern wir gehen raus
aus der kohle was macht sogar verstehen
kann wir gehen raus aus der kernkraft
und sagen alles andere muss ja klappen
und selbst wenn wir dann den atomstrom
aus trainern gemacht in der hand hat
wird man pragmatisch in einer assistent
matthias in einer absoluten notsituation
aber ich will noch mal auf deine frage
gerne zurückkommen der stil von opa
drabig auch der kommunikationsstil im
grunde nicht er nimmt die menschen
insofern finde ich das ganz gut er nimmt
die menschen mit erteilt seine
besorgnisse teilt seine bedenken bei dem
video dass du angesprochen
und das ist ganz neu in der politik war
sowas ist eine schwäche und school aber
das ist neu und insofern ist es gut die
menschen erreicht das nimmt es mit nur
am ende sind die enten fett wie es so
schön heißt das bedeutet auch er wird
auch am ende nicht nur an den worten
gemessen an den poetischen vergessen
dort und an der wahrhaftigkeit seiner
instituts sondern an dem was da hinten
rauskommt am endeffekt und das ist bald
der zeitpunkt der kommt wo man sagen
wird okay du hast die krise prophezeit
aber was tust du denn dagegen
und da nur zu sagen das muss klappen das
muss klappen reicht einfach nicht aus
deswegen muss jetzt liefern das läuft
jetzt fest gut das ist doch ein gutes
ende für deine these und damit kommen
wir zu wie ein wolf und er wie kinder
eigentlich der korona pandemie gelitten
haben und wie es kindern jetzt gerade
geht
ja selten bahn kinder so unglücklich wie
aktuell laut einer studie der tu
dortmund wächst eine generation von
jungen glücklichen kindern heran das
interessante an der studie ist dass bei
kindern das psychische wohlbefinden vor
allem seit dem frühjahr 2020 stark
bergab gegangen ist ich muss ganz klar
sagen schuld daran sind zum einen
natürlich die digitalisierung aber eben
auch die pandemie die studie hat mich
wirklich schockiert und ich finde man
muss maßnahmen ergreifen um dagegen
vorzugehen
herr kraus natürlich eine steilvorlage
an sie waren die kinder früher
glücklicher wenn sie diese studie guter
gibt es keine absoluten maßstäbe ja das
sind immer befragungen und da gibt es
kein mythisches maß
natürlich auch das war eigentlich in den
von ganz kurz rein zu gehen die studie
hat 2018 schon angefangen also die haben
nicht erst angefangen zu messen ab 2020
also ich gebe den in den beiden punkten
was die ursachen erklärung bedurft
vollkommen recht es fehlt
das soziale puls sein
die kinder waren zu hause eingesperrt
sie konnten sich in der schule im
sportunterricht am pausenhof im schulbus
nicht austoben zu hause haben sie auch
kaum gleichaltrige unsere familien wenn
sie überhaupt kinder haben haben die
kinderzahl von 1,3 im schnitt also das
ist ja auch ein ergebnis der
demografischen entwicklung und natürlich
spielt die digitalisierung eine rolle
wir wissen schon seit jahren dass unsere
kinder im alter zwischen zehn und 16
guter letzt ein bisschen nach mehr zeit
beim datteln und vor dem bildschirm und
an welchen schulen banken lassen sich
noch mal eine verschärfte natürlich zum
sage ich ja beide dinge spiel eine rolle
allerdings und jetzt kommt ein bisschen
meinem eine gegenthese ich glaube dass
wir in der erziehung der letzten 20 30
jahren der 30 jahre den kindern auch
überzogene erwartungen vermittelt haben
was lebensglück betrifft wie er sich
gibt herbert haben ja du kannst immer
alles gleich haben und du kannst immer
glücklich werden gut das ist das
ergebnis von helikopter eltern das
premper darum schauen sie mich so
war vielleicht das einzige
was
du jetzt nicht alle eltern den hügel
deutschland popularisiert vor neun
jahren nein das ist schon auch das
ergebnis dass unsere jungen leute nicht
mehr gelernt haben und das ist ein
produkt der erziehung auch in der schule
die von gewissen verwöhne einmal auch
mit unglücklichen lagen fertig zu werden
weil ich aber ganz kurz zwischen gehen
was bedeutet denn junge leute also wenn
sie jetzt sagen 20 bis 30 ich bin jetzt
28 würde ich da auch noch dazu gesagt
nein ich rede jetzt von denen im ersten
zweiten lebensjahrzehnt bisschen
volljährig sind also bis 20 ist 18 bis
sie flügge werden ja ich frage mich ob
man sich das so einfach machen kann hat
man sagen kann das ist alles so ein
produkt von helikopter eltern weil es
gibt auch ganz ganz viele kinder diesen
eben nicht das produkt von die cocktail
dann die sitzen zu hause haben auch wenn
der pandemie zu hause gesessen die
vernachlässigte genau wie die ehrliche
aber auch die lebenswirklichkeit wenn
sie zu zuhört meinte dass dann ein
bisschen mehrere zu 500 mhz 100
quadratmeter wohnung leben oder 80
quadratmeter wohnung leben obwohl die
mutter vielleicht irgendwelche arbeiten
machen muss der vater auch zu hause weil
sie immer ruhe auf wir sind da ist man
froh wenn das kind so ein bisschen er
vorsitzt und endlich mal ruhe ist auch
nicht und das ist dann gewissen so gibt
da rein dass man natürlich diese welt
entdeckt und immer weiter füllt das ist
ja nachvollziehbar nur die frage ist wie
kommt man da wieder raus also
wahrzunehmen dass die menschen in
solchen situationen auch nicht
willentlich sind sondern auch mal
reingeschmissen werden und durch die
pandemie sich das unglaublich verstärkt
seit ich glaube das gehört auch dazu
anzuerkennen dass menschen es auch nicht
einfach haben ja das ist sehr wichtig es
gibt zwei problembereiche es gibt die
kinder die
überbehütete und über betreut werden die
habe ich genannt und es gibt die
geschichte eltern nicht kümmern oder
nicht wie man können das ist jetzt aber
auch sehr schwarz weiß als würde es gab
also als würde es nur die helikopter und
nur die eltern geben die sich mit 6 3
und 6 0 und kurz dann kommen wir mit dir
irgendwo noch wenn die gerechte sache
weiter davos halbwegs vernünftig läuft
sie sprachen das thema noten an dass ich
oder die die frage ob man eigentlich
heutzutage noch lernt auch mit negativen
erfahrungen umzugehen und ich habe der
punkt ist durch ausrichtung der es auch
durchaus wichtig den sie machen denn
mein eindruck ist auch das wird aber
auch in schulen nicht mehr geleert
dieses umgehen mit einer negativen mit
der einer negativen erfahrung dass wir
beim thema noten eine isolationszelle
rennställe in der grundschule gehen das
eigene vier so gut wie gar nicht mehr 56
auslassen und auch sie haben das thema
ja auch in schulnoten generell
angesprochen wenn man sieht wie viele
menschen heute ein 1,0 abitur machen das
war vor zehn noch vor 15 jahren eine
totale seltenheit sie bekommen in den
schulen eine 1 - mit zwei drei fehler in
einer arbeit wo man sagen muss ist alles
aber es ist keine 1 mehr eine zwei minus
mit fehlern wo man sagen wir das alles
aber keine zwei mehr also man versucht
doch extrem frustration bei schülerinnen
und schülern vorzubeugen über dieses
notensystem und es ist ja interessant
dass trotz der ganzen debatten die wir
seit über 20 jahren haben weder du weißt
dass du warst damals auch teil der
bundesregierung thema pisa tests teams
tests dass wir eigentlich was das
leistungsniveau angeht 20 jahre später
eigentlich nicht besser geworden sind
sondern immer noch sagen die deutschen
mittelfeld mal geht es ein bisschen rauf
im internationalen vergleich mal wieder
ein bisschen runter und das ist das was
mich eigentlich umtreibt da komme ich
auf ein anderes thema von der
frustration hin aber zum thema bildung
und muss sagen wird eigentlich das
richtige gelehrt wird genug gelehrt und
haben wir angst jungen leuten auch
zuzumuten mal eine frustration zu
erleben
weil wir sie nicht zu trauen und wir
müssten sie eigentlich zutrauen damit
sie daraus kraft schöpfen motivation und
den willen dinge besser gegen wen hast
du abi gemacht
ganz genau noch nicht so lange her oder
dvd ist dein herz geschenkt worden also
wenn man das selber inhalte des ersten
letzten jahren so entwickeln nein auf
gar keinen fall also ich musste richtig
ackern mich hinsetze und was dafür tun
um der installation slam wurde auch
genug ausgeschöpft ja was ist denn deine
lösung du hast die these mitgebracht was
würdest du dir wünschen für deutschland
ich glaube einfach dass es super wichtig
ist dass man mit programmen dagegen
vorgeht also man sieht es ja auch zum
beispiel ein fußballverein es gibt ein
wirkliches vereins sterben in
deutschland die leute oder die jungen
leute gehen nicht mehr raus die machen
keine vernünftigen hobbys mehr die
sitzen nur noch vortritt und diesen
ganzen neuen online geschichten nicht
glaube ist super wichtig dass man das
meer fördert in der schule auch mal
fördert natürlich ist digitalisierung
wahnsinnig wichtig und das dürfen
wir müssen auch